all right so This song is called about
damn time and it is about damn time
isn't it here we go Howard preach no I'm
Gonna Let You Preach do anything you
want to say about damn time anything
that comes to your mind about this song
before you sing it I think this is an
incredible song
um I hated this song
we were writing it
so in other words you were not going to
put this on the album no it was the last
I wrote this in little wait did the
album come out this year they I wrote
this [ __ ] in February and came out this
year and it came out my album came out
in April so like I was like my album's
done I don't need no more songs I'm good
and they were like we think we made
something special if you and I was like
play it over the phone and if it's good
I'll come I'll come to studio and I
heard the Dunk Dunk
and I was like I'll be there in 10
minutes and I came and it took so many
rewrites to nail this chorus and
literally like well the verses were
freestyled so that was easy but the
chorus took forever because we had all
of these Like lyrics in there that were
just so overly thought and so too Niche
and too mean and unnecessary and finally
I was just like I'm gonna be okay okay
all right it's about damn time it used
to be about that time and then and we
were like damn is like cooler so I like
wrote this chorus a zillion times so I
was like on like version 207 I was like
I [ __ ] hate this song because now I
just love it all right anyway I'm gonna
shut up let you go don't be nervous you
guys you got this
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
turn off the music Turn Down the Lights
[Music]
[Music]
Turn Up the Music let's celebrate
I've got a feeling I'm gonna be okay
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
used to be
better turn up the music
[Music]
[Music]
turn off the music let's celebrate hey
imma be okay
[Music]
I'm coming out tonight
yeah
wow